MEMBERS. SHH. I DON'T HAVE THE
BIG GAVEL, SO I NEED EVERYONE TO
LISTEN UP. I'M ABOUT TO CALL THE
SESSION TO ORDER ON THE ROLE.
EVERYONE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'RE HERE
WITH A VERBAL. I'M HERE. OKAY.
PRESENT. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL BEGIN. THE SENATE WILL
WILL BEGIN. THE 20 2324 SECOND
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION THAT WILL
COME TO ORDER. THE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. EXCUSE ME. PLEASE.
I'LL REPEAT MY INSTRUCTIONS
AGAIN TO MEMBERS WHO WEREN'T.
WEREN'T LISTENING. AS EACH NAME
IS CALLED. IS YOUR NAME IS
CALLED. WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU
GIVE A VERBAL ACKNOWLEDGMENT
THAT YOU'RE HERE. OKAY. SO WITH
SECRETARY, PLEASE SLOWLY CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GILL.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. HERE. ATKINS.
BECKER, HERE. BLAKE. SPEER.
HERE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO. HERE.
CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD. DURAZO.
HERE. EGGMAN. GLAZER. HERE.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HERE. HURTADO.
JONES. I'M HERE. LAIRD. LIMON.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR MEN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
HERE. PORTANTINO, HERE. ROTH.
HERE. RUBIO. SEYARTO. SKINNER.
HERE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN.
HERE. UMBERG. WAHAB. HERE.
WIENER. WILK. PRESENT. DO WE
HAVE A QUORUM? QUORUM IS
PRESENT. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WOULD MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL HERE IN
OUR HEARING ROOM, PLEASE. RISE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AFTER WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I READ
FROM JOYCE RUPP PART OF LOVE IN
OUT OF THE ORDINARY HEART OF
LOVE, SOURCE OF ALL KINDNESS.
TEACHER OF THE WAYS OF GOODNESS.
YOU ARE HIDDEN IN THE POCKETS OF
DAILY LIFE WAITING TO BE
DISCOVERED. HEART OF COMFORT,
SHELTERING WINGS OF LOVE. REFUGE
FOR SAD AND LONELY ONES. YOU
EMBRACE ALL WHO BEAR LOSS.
GATHERING OUR TEARS WITH CARE.
HEART OF UNDERSTANDING. ONE WHO
GAZES UPON THE IMPERFECT, THE
INCOMPLETE, THE FLAWED, THE
WEAK. YOU NEVER STOP EXTENDING
MERCY. HEART OF GENEROSITY.
ABUNDANCE OF INSIGHT AND HOPE.
DAILY YOU OFFER US GIFTS OF
GROWTH LEADING TO CONTINUAL
TRANSFORMATION. HEART OF DEEPEST
PEACE. RESTING PLACE AT A CORE
OF OUR BEING. YOU ARE WAITING
ALWAYS FOR OUR RETURN TO THE
SACRED HOME. AMEN. AMEN.
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS. IT'S SO NICE
TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING. AS YOU
CAN SEE, WE ARE NOT MEETING IN
THE TYPICAL PLACE THE SENATE
FLOOR. WE ARE MEETING IN ROOM
1200, IN OUR SWING SPACE. WE
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF WHO HAVE
MADE ALL THESE GREAT
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR US SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE OUR WORK BECAUSE WE
ARE IN THIS SPACE AND OUR SOME
OF OUR COMMON PROCEDURES ARE NOT
IN PLACE IN TERMS OF A DESIRE TO
SPEAK. IF YOU DO WANT TO SPEAK
ON AN ITEM ON OUR AGENDA TODAY,
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. I'LL
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
ACKNOWLEDGMENT SO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO KEEP IT UP. SO WE'LL PUT YOUR
NAME ON THE LIST. THE
MICROPHONES TO YOUR RIGHT WOULD
BE THE PLACE IN WHICH WE'RE
ASKING MEMBERS, I BELIEVE, TO
SPEAK FROM A PRESENTATION.
MICROPHONE IS ON YOUR LEFT. FOR
THAT, FOR THAT PURPOSE. ALL
RIGHT. UNLESS THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR AGENDA. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING, AND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER TWO. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HART. SENATOR SKINNER IS FLOOR
MANAGING THIS MEASURE. WE'D LIKE
TO INVITE HER TO COME UP AND
PRESENT THE BILL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. YES. SENATOR
SKINNER. MAY I TURN THIS WAY? SO
I CAN. YOU CAN FACE ANY
DIRECTION YOU WISH. APPRECIATE
THAT. WHOOPS. OKAY. MEMBERS, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWO ONE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. HART
AND MAJORITY LEADER CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY. AB TWO ONE WILL
GIVE THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S NEW
DIVISION OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT, WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
LAST YEAR WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB
ONE TWO. LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE, I'M GETTING LIKE MIXED
UP. BUT ANYWAY, WHEN WE PASSED
SB ONE, TWO ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITIES TO HELP PREVENT
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES. SB ONE
TWO, THE ORIGINAL BILL DIRECTED
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO ANALYZE
CALIFORNIA'S GASOLINE MARKET AND
THE FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
PRICE SPIKES AT THE PUMP, BASED
ON THE INFORMATION GATHERED OVER
THE LAST YEAR, EXPERTS AT THE
NEW DIVISION HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
THE PRIMARY CAUSES OF PRICE
SPIKES WERE WHEN GLOBAL CRUDE
PRICES ROSE AND WHEN THERE WERE
SHORTAGES OF REFINED GASOLINE.
NOW, WHILE GLOBAL CRUDE PRICE
PRICES ARE NOT SOMETHING WE CAN
CONTROL, A SHORTAGE OF REFINED
GASOLINE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN PREPARE FOR. THESE SHORTAGES
OCCURRED WHEN OIL REFINERIES DID
NOT MAINTAIN ADEQUATE SUPPLIES
OF GASOLINE DURING PEAK DRIVING
PERIODS, WHICH MOSTLY OCCUR
DURING OUR SUMMER MONTHS BETWEEN
LABOR DAY. I MEAN MEMORIAL DAY
AND LABOR DAY, OR WHEN
REFINERIES WERE SHUT DOWN FOR
MAINTENANCE. IN RESPONSE, THIS
BILL, AB TWO ONE, GIVES THE CEC
NEW TOOLS TO HELP ENSURE
ADEQUATE GASOLINE SUPPLIES AND
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES. SO JUST
LIKE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
A STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE,
AB X TWO ONE WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE STRATEGIC
GASOLINE RESERVES. IF IT'S IF IT
PASSES THE MUSTER. AND WE'LL
DISCUSS THAT IN A MOMENT SO THAT
WHEN DEMAND AT THE PUMP IS HIGH,
WE DON'T FACE A GASOLINE
SHORTAGE, WHICH CAN DRIVE UP
PRICES. AB TWO ONE ALSO ENABLES
THE DIVISION TO COORDINATE AND
MONITOR PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
REFINERY OUTAGES. CCS ANALYSIS
FOUND THAT IF REFINERIES PLAN
AHEAD FOR THE SUMMER DIVISION
DRIVING SEASON, THERE IS LIKELY
TO BE ADEQUATE GASOLINE SUPPLY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS. GASOLINE
SHORTAGES OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS CAUSED PRICES AT TIMES
TO SPIKE BETWEEN 40 TO $0.75 PER
GALLON. IN TWO 2023, FOR
EXAMPLE, THERE WERE 63 DAYS WHEN
CALIFORNIA REFINERIES MAINTAINED
LESS THAN 15 DAYS OF GAS SUPPLY.
THE RESULTING PRICE SPIKES COST
THE AVERAGE DRIVER ABOUT $10
MORE EACH TIME THEY WENT TO THE
PUMP TO FILL THEIR VEHICLE. A
COST TO ALL CALIFORNIANS IN A
GIVEN YEAR OF ABOUT $2 BILLION.
AB TWO ONE GIVES THE CEC
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP REGS THAT
COULD REQUIRE AND NOTE THAT I
SAID COULD COULD REQUIRE
REFINERY MAINTENANCE TO BE
SCHEDULED TO AVOID MULTIPLE
REFINERY SHUTDOWNS AT THE SAME
TIME AND DURING TIMES WHEN
GASOLINE DEMAND IS HIGHEST AND
COULD REQUIRE REFINERIES TO
MAINTAIN A MINIMUM INVENTORY OF
GASOLINE SUPPLY. AND I STATE
COULD, BECAUSE AB TWO ONE DOES
NOT IN ITSELF MANDATE THESE
PROVISIONS. AND IN FACT, IT
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF THRESHOLDS
THAT THE CEC MUST MEET BEFORE
SUCH REGS COULD BE ISSUED. SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE CEC WOULD HAVE
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THE BENEFITS
OF THE REGS OUTWEIGH POTENTIAL
COSTS TO CONSUMERS, THAT THE
REGS WOULD LEAD TO GREATER FUEL
SUPPLY IN CALIFORNIA'S MARKET,
THAT THEY WOULD LEAD TO LOWER
AVERAGE RETAIL PRICES ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS, THAT THEY WOULD
REDUCE THE SEVERITY OF RETAIL
PRICE VOLATILITY, THAT IT WOULD
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF EXISTING
STORAGE TO AVOID THE COST OF
BUILDING NEW STORAGE FACILITIES,
AND THAT THE REGS WOULD PROVIDE
A PROCESS WHERE THE CEC COULD,
IF THEY ENACTED A MINIMUM
INVENTORY, WHERE IT COULD WAIVE
THAT REQUIREMENT. ADDITIONALLY,
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CEC TO
ANNUALLY EVALUATE THESE FACTORS
AND TO REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AS TO WHETHER THE REGULATIONS
MEET THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
TEST. IT ALSO CONTAINS
PROVISIONS TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND OF OUR
WORKERS. SO OUR COMMUNITIES NEAR
OIL REFINERIES AND OUR WORKERS
AT OIL REFINERIES AND IT DOES
THIS BY ENSURING THAT OUR
EXISTING REFINERY SAFETY
MEASURES REMAIN IN PLACE, AND
THAT NO NEW REGS COULD OVERTURN
ANY EXISTING SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
IT ALSO GIVES REFINERS, WORKERS,
REFINERY WORKERS A SEAT AT THE
TABLE, INCLUDING THEM ON THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT MUST BE
CONSULTED WHEN AND IF REGS ARE
DEVELOPED. IT ALSO ENSURES THAT
AN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS WORKERS
STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO SHUT
DOWN A REFINERY FOR SAFETY. SO
AS A FINAL SAFEGUARD, AB TWO ONE
ALSO CONTAINS A HARD SUNSET DATE
OF JANUARY 1ST, 2033. KEEP IN
MIND THAT AB X21 DOES NOT ASK
OIL REFINERS TO DO ANYTHING THAT
THEY HAVEN'T DONE BEFORE. DURING
THE PANDEMIC, FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA REFINERIES ROUTINELY
HAD SUBSTANTIAL QUANTITIES OF
REFINED GASOLINE PRODUCT ON HAND,
HIGHER THAN WHAT THE CEC HAS
PROJECTED MAY BE NEEDED AS A
MINIMUM SUPPLY TO AVOID PRICE
SPIKES. AND DURING WINTER
MONTHS. THE DATA SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OIL REFINERS
ROUTINELY KEEP SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNTS OF REFINED GASOLINE ON
HAND, MUCH MORE THAN THEY'VE
KEPT DURING SUMMER AND FALL.
WHEN DRIVING DEMAND IS HIGHEST.
MY DISTRICT CONTAINS AND IS
ADJACENT TO FOUR OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST REFINERIES, AND HAVING
LIVED THROUGH A NUMBER OF
DANGEROUS REFINERY INCIDENTS FOR
ME, SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT. IT'S
WHY I JOINED MY PREDECESSOR,
SENATOR HANCOCK, TO AUTHOR
LEGISLATION THAT PUT IN LAW
RULES ABOUT MAINTENANCE AND
REFINERY SAFETY. THIS BILL DOES
NOT OVERTURN THOSE RULES AND
MAINTAINS AND STRENGTHENS
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
WORKER SAFETY AND TO THE SAFETY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AT ITS CORE.
AB TWO ONE IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER, IS THERE A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? I DON'T HAVE GREAT
SIGHT LINES HERE. SO IF YOU HAVE
A HAND UP, PLEASE MAKE SURE I
CAN SEE IT. ALL RIGHT. I SEE
SENATOR DOLLY. COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. YOUR FIRST STEP.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I SAT THROUGH A 2.5
HOUR HEARING ON MONDAY REGARDING
THIS BILL. FIRST, I WANT TO SAY
I HAVE NO. I CAN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING A
SPECIAL SESSION. THIS BILL
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING URGENT.
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT IS
URGENT. THIS IS JUST, QUITE
FRANKLY, IN MY OPINION, THE
ABILITY FOR THE GOVERNOR TO LEAD
THE LEGISLATURE AROUND BY THE
NOSE IN THE IN THE LEGISLATION
ITSELF. IF YOU GO TO SECTION 25,
3.25, 35, 4.4, IT TALKS ABOUT
GIVING THE CEC THE ABILITY TO
REGULATE. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW
THE CEC IN THE FUTURE TO BE ABLE
TO REGULATE, AND ALSO TO BE ABLE
TO FIND FROM $100,000 A DAY TO
$1 MILLION A DAY. I DON'T KNOW
HOW THAT'S GOING TO DRIVE DOWN
THE COST OF OIL AND GAS IN
CALIFORNIA. ON TOP OF THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE OTHER LEGISLATION THAT'S
ALREADY ENACTED THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO BRING SHIPS INTO
PORT, WHICH IS GOING TO
CONSTRAIN THE SUPPLY OF GAS AND
OIL IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE POINT
ABOUT COVID. YEAH, NOBODY WAS
MOVING AROUND CALIFORNIA DURING
COVID. THERE WAS DEFINITELY THEY
WERE OVERFILLED BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T USING FUEL. NOBODY WAS
MOVING GOODS AND SERVICES. THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO POINT OUT,
WHICH I'VE BEEN POINTING OUT ALL
YEAR, IS THE CEC IS FUNDED BY
ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS. THIS IS
A BILL THAT IS GOING TO DO STUFF
IN THE GASOLINE AND FUEL SIDE OF
IT. SO ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR ALL THIS
WORK TO BE DONE THROUGH THE CEC.
THIS BILL GIVES THE CEC A LOT OF
POWER, JUST LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD, WHICH IS
GOING TO MEET NEXT MONTH, AND
LOOK AT THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARDS. AND IN THEIR
ESTIMATES, MAY RAISE GASOLINE
PRICES BY $0.47 A GALLON NEXT
YEAR. MEMBERS, I JUST WANT TO
SAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PRICE
GOUGING. IN THE FIRST SPECIAL
SESSION, WE HAD EARLIER THIS
YEAR, AND THE GOVERNOR NOW IS
GOING TO GET INVOLVED IN TELLING
US WHEN WE'RE GOING TO SHUT DOWN
THE REFINERIES AND DO
MAINTENANCE. THE TRADES WERE NOT
ON BOARD. THEY SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT WHO'S WHO'S
GETTING GOUGED THE MOST, WHO'S
THE WINDFALL PROFITS FROM OIL
AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
FROM THE CEC WEBSITE. YOU CAN
ALL GO TAKE A LOOK AT IT. THEY
SAID DURING THE COMMITTEE 38
MILLION GALLONS OF GASOLINE ARE
USED EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA,
ALMOST A GALLON PER PERSON.
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY $1.42 A
GALLON. THAT IS TAXED, WHETHER
IT'S LOCAL, STATE OR FEDERAL TAX.
SO WHO'S MAKING THE MONEY? WHO'S
GOUGING? CALIFORNIANS FOR EVERY
GALLON OF GAS, IT'S THE
GOVERNMENT, $1.42 FOR EVERY
SINGLE GALLON OF GAS GOES TO
TAXES. WHETHER IT'S STATE, LOCAL
OR FEDERAL. SO WHEN YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT GOUGING YOU, WHY
DON'T WE DROP THAT TAX? THAT
WILL HELP ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
COST FOR CALIFORNIANS. IT'S $54
MILLION EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT
THE TAXPAYERS GET FROM A GALLON,
FROM THE GALLONS OF GAS IN JUST
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE DIESEL THAT'S BURNED
IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS OVER A
BILLION GALLONS A YEAR AS WELL.
SO MEMBERS, I, I JUST WANT TO
SAY I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. OBVIOUSLY, I DON'T THINK
WE NEEDED TO HAVE THIS SPECIAL
SESSION SESSION. I THINK IT'S A
WASTE OF TAXPAYERS DOLLARS. AND
I STATED EARLIER THAT I THINK
THE GOVERNOR IS JUST LEADING THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND BY THE NOSE.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR A SPECIAL
SESSION. THERE'S NO REASON TO
GET INVOLVED IN THIS PART. IF
YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY HELP
CALIFORNIANS DROP THE GAS PRICE,
TAKE THE TAXES OFF FOR CHRIST'S
SAKES, I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DALI. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE, WHICH WILL PUT FURTHER
CONSTRAINTS ON CALIFORNIA'S
PETROLEUM INDUSTRY. I HEARD THE
IDIOM PASS THE MUSTER, AND IT IS
AN IDIOM THAT IS FOREIGN TO ME,
AS ENGLISH IS MY SECOND
LANGUAGE. BUT I DID LOOK IT UP
AND IT TALKS ABOUT MEASURING UP
TO EXPECTATIONS. AND WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THAT, I THINK ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS PAYING THE HIGHEST
GAS PRICES IN THE NATION, WITH
AN AVERAGE OF 4.6 $0.07 PER
GALLON. I JUST TOOK MY FAMILY ON
A ROAD TRIP, WHICH IS UNHEARD OF.
ROAD TRIPS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ANYMORE TO YOSEMITE, ONE OF THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL NATIONAL PARKS IN
OUR STATE, AND JUST IN GASOLINE
WAS OVER $250, ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. CALIFORNIA'S
PAY UPWARDS OF 30% MORE FOR
FOOD, AVERAGING $450 PER WEEK,
WHICH PUTS FURTHER PRESSURE ON
FAMILIES ON THE SAME ROAD TRIP
TO YOSEMITE, THE COST OF FOOD
FOR A TWO NIGHT, THREE DAY TRIP
TO YOSEMITE WAS OVER $600. NOW,
IF YOUR AVERAGE FAMILY IN
CALIFORNIA CAN'T EVEN GET IN THE
CAR, THROW THE KIDS IN THE CAR,
A COUPLE OF HOT DOGS AND
HAMBURGERS AND HIT THE ROAD TO
ENJOY THE NATURAL OUTDOORS OF
OUR STATE. ISN'T THAT AN
INDICATOR THAT WE ARE NOT
PASSING THE MUSTER? HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS LIKE MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET,
AND NOW THEY'RE FORCED TO MAKE
HARD CHOICES OF WHETHER TO BUY
GROCERIES TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES
OR PUT GAS IN THEIR VEHICLES.
AND THIS IS NOTHING NEW. I'VE
BEEN SERVING WITH THIS BODY FOR
TWO YEARS, BUT YET I'M SAYING
THE SAME THING, WHICH MEANS WE
HAVE NOT SOLVED CRISIS. WE HAVE
NOT PUT MONEY BACK INTO
CONSUMERS POCKETS, AND WE HAVE
NOT ENABLED THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY TO THRIVE. NOW, WE'RE ALL
SITTING HERE WHEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION, WHICH TO
ME IS A GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND
MISUSE OF PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS
BECAUSE TO GET EVERYBODY HERE IN
THE ROOM TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION, WE COULD HAVE SENT
100 FAMILIES TO YOSEMITE TO
VISIT THE NATURAL PARK. WE ALL
KNOW THAT GAS PRICES ARE AN ALL
TIME HIGH DUE TO REGULATIONS,
NOT THE GAS COMPANY GREED. WE
KNOW THAT BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT
IT. ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION,
TAXES, MANDATES ON PRODUCTION,
SPECIAL SPECIAL FUEL BLENDS,
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAM COSTS AND
MANDATORY REFINERY UPGRADES
CONTINUE THE COST PRESSURES ON
PRODUCERS. THIS ADDS YET ANOTHER
REGULATION THAT'S ALREADY LONG
LIST OF JUST MORE COSTS TO FUEL
PRODUCTION. TO FURTHER INCREASE
GAS PRICES. THIS BILL IS JUST
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE MANDATES
WITH NO CLEAR PROCESS ON HOW IT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED, OR WHO WILL
PAY FOR IT. BUT WE ALL KNOW THE
ANSWER, AND OUR CONSTITUENTS
KNOW THE ANSWER. CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE PAYING FOR THIS NOW IF
WE TRULY WANTED TO LOWER THE
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS, WE WOULD
DO IT BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW TO DO
IT. THAT IS WHAT IS EXPECTED OF
US, AND THAT IS WHAT PASSING THE
MUSTER TEST MEANS. WE NEED TO
STOP TALKING IN IDIOMS AND START
FIXING OUR STATE. THAT MEANS
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION. IT IS NOT
SATISFACTORY. IT IS ABSENT OF
CAREFUL SCRUTINY AND IT NEEDS
MORE EVALUATION. SO IF WE TRULY
ARE GOING TO PASS THE MUSTER, AS
WE SAY IN THIS BILL, I ASK THAT
THIS BODY CEASE DOING THE
GOVERNOR'S BIDDING BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LONG LIST OF BILLS THAT
WOULD PROVE COST EFFECTIVENESS
TO OUR CONSUMERS. WE'VE GOT IT.
IT'S IN OUR HANDS. WE'VE ALL GOT
THEM. SO AT WHAT POINT DO WE SAY
NO TO THE GOVERNOR AND WE SAY NO
TO THESE EXTRAORDINARY SESSIONS,
WHICH THIS IS MY SECOND IN TWO
YEARS. AND TAKE BACK OUR POWER
AS A STATE LEGISLATURE,
INDEPENDENT OF THE GOVERNOR.
THIS BILL IS UNACCEPTABLE. WE
KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER. WE MUST
DO BETTER BY BEING HERE TODAY. I
KNOW YOUR GOAL IS TO DO BETTER.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MEMBERS? SENATOR GROVE, I SEE
YOUR HAND. ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO
GET THEIR HAND UP SO I CAN MAKE
SURE I HAVE THEM IN THE QUEUE? I
SEE. GOT IT. OKAY, SENATOR
GROVE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL, WHICH INTENDS TO
REDUCE THE GAS PRICE VOLATILITY.
BUT I COMPEL YOU TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT WILL DO JUST THE
OPPOSITE. ON ONE HAND, THIS BILL
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE PUBLIC HAS
COME TO EXPECT WITH US AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY. WE ROUTINELY
KICK COMPLICATED ISSUES TO OUR
UNELECTED, BUREAUCRATIC AGENCIES
AND GIVE THEM FULL AUTHORITY TO
DO IMPLEMENT REGULATIONS THAT
WILL BE HARMFUL TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. ON THE OTHER HAND,
THE BILL IS WHAT THE PUBLIC,
LIKE I SAID, HAS COME TO EXPECT.
AND IN RESPECT TO THIS BILL, IT
REALLY DOESN'T DO A WHOLE LOT
SINCE MOST OF THE SPECIFICS WILL
BE DETERMINED AT A LATER DATE BY
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, THE BROAD
REGULATORY AUTHORITY THIS BILL
IS GIVING THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
INCREASE PRICES TO THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE AND THAT
RELY ON GASOLINE TO DROP THEIR
CHILDREN OFF FOR SCHOOL OR TO GO
TO WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE
FACT THAT THE STORAGE
REQUIREMENT DECREASES PRICES IS
AT MY CONCLUSION OR BIG OIL'S
CONCLUSION. IT'S WHAT THE STAFF
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
BELIEVES WILL HAPPEN. THERE IS
ALSO A LIKELY SCENARIO THAT
GASOLINE SHORTAGES WILL TAKE
EFFECT BECAUSE OF THE MILLION
DOLLAR A DAY PENALTY THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE CHARGED TO
REFINERS, AND THAT WOULD BE ON A
DOWNSTREAM SITUATION, WHICH I'LL
EXPLAIN. WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION CLAIMS THAT THE
INCREASED STORAGE WILL HAVE SAVE
CONSUMERS MONEY BY SMOOTHING OUT
GAS SPIKES, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THAT THEORY. AND IT
CERTAINLY DIDN'T FACTOR IN THE
INCREASED COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ADDITIONAL STORAGE AND
DOWNSTREAM SUPPLY SHORTAGES.
LIKE MOST OF THE THINGS DONE IN
HEAVY REGULATORY HAND OF
GOVERNMENT, THIS IS BOUND TO
INCREASE THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
INSTEAD OF LOWER IT. IT'S EASY
TO MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST COST
OF GASOLINE FOR THIS VERY
REASON. THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARDS AB FIVE, WHICH
RESTRICTED OUR TRUCKING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND INCREASED THE
COST OF TRUCKING AND
TRANSPORTATION REQUIREMENTS, OUR
SPECIAL BLEND AND MANY OF THESE
OTHERS REGULATORY PROCESSES HAVE
DRIVEN UP THE COST OF
CALIFORNIA'S FUEL, MAKING IT THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION. THERE'S A
HANDFUL OF MAJOR REFINERIES THAT
ARE STILL LEFT HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA 50 YEARS AGO. WE
HAVE TO. WE USED TO HAVE 50 THAT
WE USED TO HAVE A DOZEN MORE
REFINERIES 50 YEARS AGO, AND
WE'VE LOST THEM IN THE LAST 50
YEARS. A HANDFUL OF MAJOR
REFINERIES ARE LEFT. AND TO SHUT
DOWN THE RIPPLE, IF JUST A FEW
SHUT DOWN, THE RIPPLE EFFECTS
WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC TO OUR
CONSUMERS. OUR REFINERIES ALSO
PROVIDE ABOUT 90% OF NEVADA'S
FUEL AND ALSO 50% OF ARIZONA'S
FUEL. SO I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THAT I THINK ALL OF US NEED TO
ANSWER IN THE MEDIA SHOULD
PROBABLY PRESS EVERY LEGISLATOR
WHO VOTES FOR THIS BILL ON THIS
QUESTION. WE HAVE THE SAME
SUPPLY CHAIN. CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
GET A DIFFERENT SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
ITS CRUDE OIL THAN IT DOES IF IT
SUPPLIES IT TO CALIFORNIA,
ARIZONA OR NEVADA. SO WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT WE HAVE THE SAME
SUPPLY CHAIN. WE GET IT FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES. IT COMES
ACROSS OUR ECOSYSTEM. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT SEVERAL TIMES.
WE DON'T PRODUCE IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ANYMORE. WE CAN'T GET
PERMITS SPECIFICALLY IN MY
DISTRICT. SO THESE SHIPS COME
FROM ECUADOR. THEY COME FROM
IRAQ. THEY COME FROM SAUDI
ARABIA, AND THEY COME ACROSS OUR
ECOSYSTEM. THEY COME TO OUR
PORTS, OUR PORTS AND OUR LABOR
AND OUR UNIONS. THEY OFFLOAD
THAT PRODUCT AND THEY TAKE IT TO
OUR REFINERIES VIA TRUCKING AND
TRANSPORTATION. THAT FUEL GETS
PROCESSED IN THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
BY THE SAME REFINERIES THAT PUT
IT INTO TRUCKS. SOME PIPELINE
AND RAIL CAR, BUT MOSTLY
TRUCKING AND TRANSPORTATION. AND
THEY PROVIDE THAT TO OUR
RETAILERS OR OUR DOWNSTREAM
FACILITIES, WHICH ARE THE GAS
STATIONS THAT ALL OF OUR
CONSUMERS USE EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO PUT FUEL IN THEIR CAR. THOSE
SAME TRUCKS, THAT SAME PROCESS,
THE SAME POINT OF ORIGIN, THE
SAME POINT OF ORIGIN, WHICH THE
PRODUCT ORIGINATES FROM THE SAME
PROCESS IT GOES THROUGH. THERE'S
NO DIFFERENCE CAN DROP OFF FUEL
IN BLYTHE, CALIFORNIA, AT A GAS
STATION, AND IT'S OVER $5 A
GALLON FOR GAS. AS OF
YESTERDAY'S AVERAGE, THE DAY
BEFORE IS AVERAGE LAST MONTH'S
AVERAGE. THEY CAN CROSS THAT
STATE LINE INTO ARIZONA AND SAVE
$1.30 A GALLON PER GAS PER
GALLON $1.30. WHAT'S MAGIC ABOUT
THAT STATE LINE? IT'S THE SAME
PROCESS, THE SAME SUPPLY CHAIN,
THE SAME TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
YOU CAN'T SAY WE USE UNION LABOR
AND THEY DON'T BECAUSE THEY USE
UNION LABOR PROCESS THAT FUEL
THAT THEY GET AS WELL. BUT ONCE
THEY CROSS THAT STATE LINE, IT'S
A $1.30 A GALLON CHEAPER. WHAT'S
MAGIC ABOUT THAT STATE LINE?
IT'S THE SAME TRUCK THAT STOPS
IN BLYTHE, DRIVES ACROSS THE
BORDER AND GOES TO BULLHEAD CITY
AND DRIVES TO THEIR GAS STATION.
AND IT'S $1.30 A GALLON CHEAPER
IN NEVADA. IT'S LIKE $0.90 A
GALLON CHEAPER. WHAT'S THE MAGIC
ABOUT THAT STATE LINE? YOU GUYS
SAY IT'S NOT YOUR POLICIES. IT'S
NOT AB5. IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARDS. IT'S
NOT LETTING CARB REGULATE THE
INDUSTRY TO A POINT WHERE THEY
HAVE TO INCREASE FUEL PRICES.
IT'S NOT ANY PART OF THAT. YOU
WON'T ADMIT TO THAT. YOU WON'T
ADMIT TO THE SUBSIDIZED GREEN
ENERGY TECHNOLOGY THAT GOES, AND
I'M NOT AGAINST GREEN ENERGY. MY
COUNTY PRODUCES 58% OF THE GREEN
ENERGY IN THIS STATE, AND THERE
ARE ONLY 58 COUNTIES. YOU NEED
US FOR THAT GREEN ENERGY, AND WE
PRODUCE 70% OF THE STATE'S
FOSSIL FUELS. LET'S JUST FIGURE
OUT WHAT MAKES IT MAGIC TO
REDUCE THAT $1.30 A GALLON. WHEN
YOU CROSS THAT STATE LINE AND
REDUCE OUR PRICE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE SAME MANNER.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER BROUGHT UP
IS THE ISSUE ABOUT THE CEC BEING
FUNDED BY OUR PGA BILLS. WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST COST OF LIVING. WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST HOUSING PRICES.
IF YOU CAN AFFORD A PHONE, YOU
CAN'T A HOME, YOU CAN'T AFFORD
THE INSURANCE AND YOU CAN'T
AFFORD TO FUEL THE GAS IN YOUR
CAR. IF YOU CAN AFFORD THE
INSURANCE, YOU CAN'T AFFORD THE
PGA BILL. PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE TRIPLING.
I HAD ONE PERSON TELL ME SIX
MONTHS AGO THEIR PGA RATE OR
THEIR PGA BILL WAS $600 A MONTH,
AND NOW IT'S $1,400 A MONTH. ALL
OF THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT
WE PUT AS WHEN WE PASS POLICIES
TO AFFECT THE UTILITY RATES AND
HAVE OUR CONSUMERS PAY, OUR
CONSTITUENTS PAY FOR THAT, FUNDS
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. SO THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT.
NUMBER ONE, IT'S UNAFFORDABLE TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S THE
POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF THE
BUILDING, THIS BUILDING THAT
MAKE IT, MAKES IT HAPPEN.
SENDING THIS REGULATORY
AUTHORITY TO AN UNELECTED,
BUREAUCRATIC AGENCY IS JUST
GOING TO INCREASE THE COST OF
FUEL. NEVADA AND ARIZONA, WHERE
WE SUPPLY THEIR FUEL ALMOST 90%
IN ONE CASE, HAS ALREADY FIGURED
OUT HOW TO REDUCE IT. $1.30 A
GALLON. I SUGGEST THAT WE REACH
OUT TO NEVADA AND ARIZONA, WE
FIND OUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING, AND
WE INSTANTLY REDUCE OUR FUEL
COSTS TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL. WITH THAT,
OBVIOUSLY, INCREASE THE COST OF
FUEL TO ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
GROFF. NEXT UP, CALL THE FRONT.
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO SUPPORT AB
TWO ONE MEMBERS. WE ALL KNOW
THAT GASOLINE PRICES ARE TOO
HIGH FOR CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THEY EAT INTO
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES, MAKING IT
HARDER TO GET TO AND FROM WORK
AND TO AFFECT THE COST OF GOODS
AND SERVICES AND RETAIL SPIKES
IN COSTS ARE DETRIMENTAL, AND
THEY HURT EVERYBODY. AND EVEN
THOUGH PETROLEUM IS PRODUCED IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND IN MY
DISTRICT, PRICES AT THE PUMP ARE
OFTEN HIGHER THAN IN THE URBAN
AREAS OF THE STATE. THE COST OF
FUEL IMPACTS THE POOR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, MUCH
MORE SO THAN MANY OTHERS. AND IT
AFFECTS NOT ONLY FAMILIES. IN MY
DISTRICT, BUT OUR FARMERS, FARM
WORKERS, AND THE BOUNTY OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCE THAT COMES
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY REGION.
AS WE'VE HEARD IN OUR POLICY AND
FISCAL COMMITTEE'S COMMITTEE
HEARINGS THIS WEEK, THE CAUSES
OF THOSE HIGHER PRICES ARE
EXTREMELY COMPLEX, GIVING THE
STATE AGENCY BROAD AUTHORITY
OVER GASOLINE SUPPLY AND DEMAND
CAN BE A CHALLENGE, AND IT
RAISES SOME VALID ISSUES OF
CONCERN. THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT. I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
NOT SO MUCH BECAUSE IT CONFERS
NEW AUTHORITY TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION, BUT BECAUSE AT ITS
CORE, IT IS DESIGNED TO HELP
CONTROL UNNATURAL AND COSTLY
PRICE HIKES THAT HURT CONSUMERS.
AND IT ALSO ESTABLISHES CLEAR
GUARDRAILS ON THE AUTHORITY IN
ORDER TO PROTECT OUR REFINERY
WORKERS, LOCAL COMMUNITIES, AND
TO ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION'S
ACTION MUST BENEFIT CONSUMERS,
MUST BENEFIT CONSUMERS SO THEY
CAN TAKE ACTION OR NOT,
DEPENDING ON THOSE FINDINGS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS, THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT ANY REGULATION
ADOPTED MUST, AND I QUOTE,
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
EMPLOYEES, LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
THE PUBLIC. END OF QUOTE. THAT'S
THE FINDING THAT THEY MUST MEET
REGULATORS MUST DEMONSTRATE THAT
REGULATIONS WILL INCREASE, NOT
DECREASE SUPPLY, AND THAT IT
WILL LEAD TO LOWER AVERAGE
RETAIL PRICES THAT WOULD EXIST,
THAT WOULDN'T EXIST WITHOUT THE
MINIMUM LEVEL OF INVENTORIES.
FINALLY, THEY MUST DETERMINE
THAT REGULATIONS AFFECTING THE
MINIMAL LEVELS OF INVENTORY WILL
REDUCE THE SEVERITY OF THE
RETAIL PRICE SPIKES, WHICH WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES. SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF FINDINGS THAT HAVE TO BE MET
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND THIS IS ABOUT A
BALANCED APPROACH. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, I SUPPORT AB TWO ONE
AND ITS PROTECTION AGAINST
HIGHER GAS PRICES FOR CONSUMERS
AND FOR THE NEW WORKER SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AMENDED INTO THE
BILL BY THE SENATE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CABALLERO. DOES ANY OTHER MEMBER
WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE,
SEEING NO HANDS UP, SENATOR
SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU,
MEMBERS, FOR YOUR COMMENTS. SO
IN CLOSE, AS I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING COMMENTS, JUST LIKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE, AB
TWO ONE WILL ENABLE CALIFORNIA
IF THE CEC MEETS THE FINDINGS
THAT ARE BUILT INTO THE BILL TO
HAVE STRATEGIC GASOLINE
RESERVES, SO THAT WHEN DEMAND AT
THE PUMP IS HIGH, WE DON'T FACE
A GASOLINE SHORTAGE THAT CAN
DRIVE UP PRICES, WHICH IN RECENT
YEARS HAVE RAISED THE PRICE OF A
GALLON OF GAS BETWEEN 40 TO
$0.75 A GALLON. AB TWO ONE ALSO
ENABLES THE DIVISION, AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED, THE ABILITY TO
COORDINATE AND MONITOR PLANNED
AND UNPLANNED REFINERY OUTAGES
SO THAT MAINTENANCE OCCURS AND
THAT MAINTENANCE IS DONE SO THAT
WE ARE SAFE. BUT MAINTENANCE IS
NOT DONE BY MULTIPLE REFINERIES
AT A TIME WHEN WE MIGHT NEED
SUPPLY THE MOST. AND THEN, AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE,
BEFORE THE NEW REQUIREMENTS ARE
ADOPTED, THE CEC HAS TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
REGULATIONS, BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE POTENTIAL COST TO CONSUMERS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS, AND THAT THE
MAINTENANCE TO BE SCHEDULED
WOULD AVOID SHUTDOWNS AT TIMES.
AS I MENTIONED, WHEN THE DEMAND
IS HIGHEST AND POTENTIALLY THAT
MINIMUM SUPPLY REQUIREMENT. BUT
AGAIN, ONLY IF THE CEC CAN MAKE
ALL OF THE FINDINGS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MODESTO MOST OR
SAID, MOST CLEARLY ARTICULATED,
JUST NOW, AB TWO ONE PROVISIONS
ARE ALSO DESIGNED TO PROTECT
SAFETY. THE SAFETY OF OUR OIL
REFINERIES, THEIR WORKERS AND
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES, AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
TO PROTECT OUR CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. NO. NO. ARCHULETA. Ã. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. AYE.
BECKER. AYE AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY. NO.
DODD. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN. NGUYEN.
NO. NO. NILO. NO. NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH.
RUBIO. SEGATO. SKINNER. AYE.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE AYE.
WILK. NO. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD.
AYE AYE. DODD. EGGMAN. GLAZER.
AYE AYE. HURTADO. NO. MENGIBAR.
MIN. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. RUBIO. SEYARTO. AYES 23.
AYES 23. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SENATE.
THIRD READING FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. THIS IS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER TWO. SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE RELATIVE TO
FINAL ADJOURNMENT OF THE 20 2324
SECOND EXTRAORDINARY SESSION OF
THE LEGISLATURE. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SCR 2-2. THIS IS
DESPITE STRONG OBJECTION BY
SENATOR PADILLA, WHO WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO STAY HERE FOR MANY
MORE DAYS ALONG WITH SENATOR
UMBERG. THIS ONCE PASSED BY OUR
HOUSE AND THE ASSEMBLY WILL
ADJOURN THE SECOND EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION. MR. PRESIDENT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR, AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE AND ON
THIS RESOLUTION? ANY DISCUSSION?
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. MR. MORNING. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
RESOLUTION BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ENGAGING IN POLITICAL THEATRICS
RATHER THAN HAVING AN OPEN AND
HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA'S TAXES AND FEES
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR RISING FUEL
COSTS. IF WE WERE TRULY
COMMITTED TO FINDING SOLUTIONS,
LEADERSHIP WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
THE BODY TO CONSIDER MORE THAN
ONE BILL DURING THIS SESSION.
BUT INSTEAD, ALL OTHER PROPOSALS
WERE EITHER NOT REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE OR BLOCKED FROM BEING
INTRODUCED. EVERY PROPOSAL
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PUT TO A VOTE
BEFORE THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE WE ARE NOT
UNDERMINING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, A PROCESS THAT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE TRANSPARENT SO ELECTED
OFFICIALS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IF THE PROCESS HAD
BEEN FOLLOWED, WE COULD HAVE
SAVED AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS
BETWEEN $7 AND $11 EVERY TIME
THEY FILLED UP THEIR TANKS FOR
THE 550,000 WORKERS WHOSE
COMMUTE IS LONGER THAN 90
MINUTES, THIS WOULD HAVE MEANT
AN ANNUAL SAVINGS OF MORE THAN
$500. THAT'S SENATORS. I WANT TO
JUST REMIND YOU THAT THE
RESOLUTION AT HAND IS THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF DEBATE. SO IF
YOU COULD PLEASE KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TO THE RESOLUTION AT
HAND. THANK YOU. SO GOING BACK,
I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT OUR
LEADERSHIP DID NOT ALLOW ME AND
OTHERS TO INTRODUCE BILLS TO
EASE THE UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL
BURDEN IMPOSED ON DRIVERS AND TO
ADDRESS THE BROADER ISSUE OF
AFFORDABILITY IN THE STATE. I
STRONGLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION? MEMBERS ON THE
RESOLUTION AT HAND, SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. MR.
PRESIDENT, SENATE RULES ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED. THEY'RE USED
EQUALLY. THEY'RE USED
APPROPRIATELY. AND PER THE
GOVERNOR'S RESOLUTION, THE
PROPOSALS WEREN'T GERMANE. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR THE ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR MCGUIRE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALY. NO. DODD. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN. WHEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO. SKINNER. AYE.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. AYE. WILK. NO!
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE LAST TIME. DODD. EGGMAN.
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN. RUBIO.
CIERTO. ON A VOTE OF 25 TO 8,
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL RIGHT, THERE WE GO. I'M NOT
GOING TO END WITH A TRIVIA
QUESTION. JUST A PREDICTION THAT
THE METS ARE GOING TO BEAT THE
YANKEES IN THE WORLD SERIES IN
SIX GAMES AND, MR. PRESIDENT,
THE DESK IS CLEAR. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR, FOR YOUR
YEARS OF SERVICE. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR FROM
ORINDA FOR YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE
TO ALL OF OUR OUTGOING MEMBERS.
IF WE CAN PLEASE GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE AND THANK THEM
FOR THE SERVICE. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. MR. PRESIDENT, WE
SAID THAT WE WOULD WORK QUICKLY.
WE SAID THAT WE WOULD WORK
EFFICIENTLY. AND THAT'S WHAT THE
SENATE HAS DONE. BUT WE HAVE
ALSO TAKEN TIME TO HAVE
THOUGHTFUL AND RESPECTFUL DEBATE
AND THAT'S ON AN ISSUE THAT IS
SO IMPACTFUL TO 40 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. AND THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF GAS PRICES. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
SENATOR FROM GARDENA FOR
CHAIRING OUR SPECIAL COMMITTEE
ON FUEL SUPPLIES. THE SENATOR
FROM BIEBER FOR BEING THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE. I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY FOR ALL OF HER
WORK THAT SHE HAS PUT INTO THIS
ISSUE FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS. WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO SENATOR SKINNER
AND FOR STEPPING IN TO CHAIR THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID
NOT AND WE DID NOT CONGRATULATE
SENATOR CABALLERO, WHO JUST
CELEBRATED HER 40TH ANNIVERSARY.
CONGRATULATIONS. IF YOU CAN GIVE
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE DESK STAFF. WE HAVE THE
BEST STAFF IN THE WORLD. I AM SO
GRATEFUL TO YOU, BERNIE. THANK
YOU TO THE ENTIRE TEAM, TO OUR
SECRETARY. IT HAS TAKEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORT AND
ENERGY TO BE ABLE TO GET US IN
HERE AND IN THE BEAUTIFUL DIGS
OF ROOM 1200, AS THE NEW LIGHTS
ARE GOING IN. AND I JUST WANT TO
END IT RIGHT HERE AND SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM, NO MATTER WHAT
SIDE OF THE AISLE YOU ARE ON, I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING TIME TO BE ABLE TO
COME INTO SACRAMENTO, TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
SPECIAL SESSION, VALUABLE TIME
AWAY FROM THE COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU SO PROUDLY SERVE AND DELIVER
FOR EACH DAY. MR. PRESIDENT,
UNTIL NEXT TIME, THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY,
DECEMBER 2ND, 2024 AT 12 P.M.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE. THE
2324 SECOND EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION IS NOW ADJOURNED.